[Music]
happy birthday
Happy Birthday
Kylie Jenner pulls out all the stops for
her daughter stormy's fifth birthday I'm
obsessed with it the makeup mogul's
little girl celebrated her big day on
Wednesday with a unicorn themed party
and in true Kardashian Jenner fashion it
was Birthday Bash goals thank you that
right there is the entrance to the party
a giant inflatable stormy tunnel and if
it looks familiar that's because it's a
whole lot like the entrance to stormy
world you know stormy's second b day
Soiree
flash forward to Wednesday guests enter
the tunnel to the party making their way
through rainbow arches oh and let's not
forget the Unicorn balloons stormy and
her Pals snagged candy from a unicorn
pinata took a ride down the rainbow
slide painted ceramic unicorns and made
glitter slime at a slime station but no
birthday is complete without cake and
stormy she blew out the candles on a
shimmering pastel rainbow sweet treat
while sitting under a pink and purple
balloon arch and if all that weren't
festive enough stormy's fifth birthday
came with merch people yep that shirt
breaks down five years in today's months
weeks hours minutes seconds amazing of
course Kylie shares Stormy with her
on-again off-again boyfriend Travis
Scott the two also have a son air who
turned one-year-old on Thursday don't
worry guys he had merch for his
Milestone birthday too swag reading heir
to the throne I can't of course baby air
was originally named wolf Webster a name
Choice Kylie says she made in a Panic
before leaving the hospital wolf was
never on our list okay
um it just was actually something Chloe
suggested and I liked it and I liked the
name I don't think anything I still like
I love it I love it I like wolf I just
wasn't him okay okay so it wasn't
against
like we really didn't have a name I just
thought it was gonna just come to us
when we saw him
and it didn't I felt the pressure to
choose a name so we just did Wolf
Webster in that moment and right after I
signed the birth certificate I was like
what did I just do Kylie and Travis
waited almost a year to make the big
name reveal and opened up about the
whole thing on her family's Hulu series
what are we gonna do about the name have
you thought any more about that yeah I
think we know his official name and I'm
not gonna announce it yet because God
forbid we change it again Travis
actually still changes his name a few
times he'll come back and be like I
really like this name and then for the
day he'll call him that and I'm like
we can't do this again all this comes
after A source told ET that Kylie and
the rapper are on a break adding
although they aren't together right now
it doesn't mean it's over for good and
when it comes to the kiddos E.T Source
says the two love and respect each other
and will continue to co-parent
[Music]